september dane says i have to do it
again
my things weren't properly folded she
says who cares how they're folded
they're going to get all messed up
anyway
it's good you've got help watch
nymeria gloves
impressive shut up now myria
gloves
i have something for you and it has to
be packed
very carefully a present
close the door
this is no toy
be careful you don't cut yourself
you're so skinny so were you
i had the blacksmith make it for you
special i won't hack a man's head off
but it can poke him full of holes if
you're quick enough
i can be quick you'll have to work at it
every day
how does it feel do you like the balance
i think so first lesson
sticking with the pointy end i know it's
end to use
i'm going to miss you
careful
all the best swords have names you know
sansa can keep her sewing needles
i've got a needle of my own
you